greetings everyone this is Rob Sanders
from simply learned and today we're
going to talk about how to set up a vent
tracking in Google Analytics so welcome
and let's get started so many of you out
there have a website similar to the one
I'm looking at now this is a nonprofit
that I work with I'm a foundation and
like this website and probably like your
website you probably have some
interactivity on there that needs to be
tracked for example buttons if you have
buttons like this one that says donate
or newsletter signup or there's a PDF
download or a video that needs to be you
know tracked based on the amount of
people who click on the play button so I
mean all sorts of interactivity on a
website have you ever wondered how to
track that well there is a way to track
them because by default Google Analytics
can't track interactivity and engagement
on your website like you probably want
to have your website tracked so if you
have buttons and videos and things of
that nature that you want to have
tracked but you're gonna need a vent
tracking and if you're in analytics and
you're always wandering around the data
and you happen to find yourself under
events well if you want a vent on your
website and you want data to populate
under behavior top events you're going
to need to set up event tracking so
event tracking is a two-part process and
we're going to talk about that two-part
process the first part of that is to
identify what you want to track okay so
if we go back to our example website
here I'm a foundation and we noted
there's a lot to track here we got a
donate Now button we got a newsletter
sign up we have some social icons okay
we got a donate Now button here we got a
play button here and all sorts of
interactivity you know we've got a
button here that says you know purchase
tickets for an upcoming event I can go
throughout the website and find
different buttons and things to track
let me just say this
there's no shortage of what you can
track on your website with event
tracking so event tracking is just
basically in layman's terms
tracking engagement on your site because
Google Analytics by default is only
gonna track page view data meaning how
somebody got to your website what page
they looked at how long they stayed on
that page what page they left from more
or less their timing how long somebody
stays on the website and what pages they
look at so there's more to website than
just how long somebody stayed on a page
and so in this example we want to be
able to track everything here not just
the donate Now button but everything
because once you get the hang of event
tracking then it's very easy to set up
okay so step one identify what you want
to track okay so there's a lot we want
to track we're just gonna use one
example to start off with and it's gonna
be this donate Now button okay so this
donate Now button we want to track now
we have a newsletter sign up we have
Facebook and and that's fine you could
track all that but for the sake of going
through a step-by-step process today
let's just focus on the donate Now
button what's focused on the Dooney Now
button and then we'll come back and
start tracking these other things but
this is what we want to track to start
out with okay so step one identify what
you want to track now when it comes to
tracking events on a website you want to
identify those events so we did that by
choosing this donate Now button now once
we identify what we want to track we
need to assign two parameters for that
event so with the event tracking you
have three parameters but one is
actually optional so you have to manded
mandatory parameters that you have to
assign to everything you want to track
on your website and that's the category
and then the action so event label or
label is the third parameter but again
that's optional okay so basically when
we identify an event our website we want
to assign it a category and
action okay so why do we want to assign
it a category in action because when we
are an analytics under behavior under
events pop events we can see we have
different categories here and we have
different actions we have different
labels so if I click on any one of these
dimensions I'm gonna be able to see some
of the parameters have entered in for
previous events I'm tracking okay so the
whole idea is you want to be able to
group different events together into a
category and assign an action and assign
a label to it that's really what you're
doing you're just grouping and
identifying the events you're trying to
track and so in this case I have this
donate Now button sitting in the header
okay in fact I have a lot of things
sitting in the header so if I wanted to
and I want to track all these buttons I
can create a category called header and
then if I track all these buttons all
these buttons can sit in that same
category if I want it to
or I can create a separate category for
each of these buttons it's up to you how
you organize your categories because
basically all you're doing is giving a
name to what you're trying to track and
the name is equivalent to a category so
in this case the donate now buttons very
important I'm just gonna call it
category header donate now I need to
give an action to each category and so
in this case I'm just gonna say click
because that's what the action is doing
it's it's somebody's taking the action
of clicking now if it's a video and it's
a play button I can assign an action of
play it's up to you whatever you name
these parameters you just need to be
organized and methodical about what you
name it that's all and so in this case
header donate and then click OK and so
that's our category in action and so
that's clearly step 2 so step 1 identify
what you want to track step 2 assign a
category action and/or label but
remember label is optional so if we go
back in analytics here I could see some
categories and if I click on action I
could see some actions that I've named
now step 3 so we've identified in step 1
what we want to track
assign a category in action so step
three is going into Google tag manager
to set up the event okay so if you're
not familiar with Google tag manager
then you can easily just you know do a
Google search for Google tag manager and
basically you'll have all sorts of
information on it there's a good video
overview of tag manager here that you
can watch so tag manager basically is
what we want to use to set up a vent
track you know tag managers use for a
lot of different things but the main
thing we're doing here is setting an
event for our website and so I'm logged
in to the same email address i'm using
for analytics okay so now i'm in tag
manager and i want to set up my event
for this donate Now button so what do I
need to do well for every event I want
to set up I need to set up a tag okay so
if I go to tags I can see I already have
some tags set up and some of these are
events and so when you actually set up a
tag I recommend having a naming
convention so here you can see any event
we set up we start out by calling it GA
- of that - whatever it is we're trying
to set up and so in this case we want to
set up a new tag for the donate now
button on our website so we're in Google
tag manager because tag manager is
what's gonna fire that event so if I
click on new okay and I click on tag
configuration I'm gonna choose Google
Analytics and then I'm going to choose
event as my track type so we want the
data to show up in Google Analytics and
we're tracking an event we're not
tracking a pantry we're tracking an
event and so now remember in step two
you identified what you want to call
that category you identify what you want
to call that action and you have some
optional parameters like label so first
things first header donate the name
of our category and our action is clique
and if you want to add in a label and a
value so if you want to assign a value
you can if you want to add in a label
you can okay those are optional so you
just need to focus on category action
and then the last setting here that's
probably worth mentioning is a non
interaction hit okay so this is
automatically set to false and why is it
set to false because it's a non
interaction no that's false we want this
event if somebody clicks on the header
donate to be an interaction so for
example if I land on this page here and
I click on that donate Now button that
I'm tracking as an event and I actually
leave the site because I have my
settings set to false
I want that click to be an interaction
then analytics is not going to count a
bounce if I change it to true so from
false to true then that means it is
going to be a non interaction if
somebody lands on the page and there's
somebody clicks on the button so I don't
want it to be a balance I want it to be
an interaction so my advice is leave it
set to false we're going to choose
Google Analytics as our setting here
this is our variable for Google
Analytics so in other words that
variable is set to our Analytics
property ID and more or less that's what
you need to do to set up the tag okay
you need to in step 2 identify the
category in action and/or label and/or
value now value can be anything you want
you're assigning a numerical value so if
you just assign 1 anytime that event
fires in analytics it's going to have a
value of 1 okay and so we have our non
interaction set to fall so anytime the
event fires it's going to count as an
interaction and therefore not count as
heat bounce if somebody landed on that
page so that's more or less all you need
to do to set up the tag in Google tag
manager now if somebody else is setting
up the tag for you then again you want
to revert to step 2
you want to be able to give
that person the appropriate category
action and/or label and value why
because you're the one that's going to
be going into Google Analytics and
you're the one that's going to have to
go to behavior events top events and
look for the particular app category in
action and or label so you need to be
able to communicate that information to
whomever is setting up the tag now if
it's you great you already know what it
is because you're entering that
information into tag manager so in this
case I'm gonna go ahead and choose a
variable for my label parameter and why
do I want to do that because in tag
manager I have something at my disposal
called variables and variables allow you
to see specifically things that are
being tracked so in this case I choose
page path
okay so page path is a URL and why did I
choose page path as my variable for the
parameter label because if somebody does
click on the header' donate button and
the header donate button on our website
is on every page so if I go to the
children's page I'm still gonna see that
a header donate button and so for me I
want to be able to see what page
somebody clicked on that hit or donate
button and so this allows me to actually
see in Google Analytics
what page somebody clicked on the head
or donate down button and so now if I go
back to GTM Google tag manager I have a
category I have an action and I have a
label which is a variable okay so note
that in Google tag manager you have a
lot of different variables at your
disposal and variables are there to help
you identify specifically what is being
tracked so take a look at all the
variables at your disposal and tag
manager in this example I'm using page
path so now once you set up your tag
pretty straightforward again tag types
Google Analytics track type is event you
are assigning the category action end or
label end
value you're changing or leaving the
default in place for non interaction hit
and then you're choosing the variable
for Google Analytics which is your
property ID so once you've done that you
have a tag the second part of setting up
a tag is to assign a trigger to that tag
so tag manager needs to be able to know
when to fire that event and so here I'm
going to look at a trigger I've already
set up for this particular event and so
if I click on it I'll be able to see
that what it is is a click on some links
not all links but some links I'm
actually saying hey Google tag manager
fire this event when the click ID equals
header donate button now it just so
happens that if somebody did click on
this donate Now button they're going to
go to another website in this case
Network for good calm so in tag manager
I could have set the trigger to equal
URL equal instead of click ID I could
have said URL equal network for good
comm so that could have been my logic
for my trigger in this case I decided to
go with the click ID and so in this case
that button has an ID associated with it
called header donate button so if you
wanted to use click ID for your event
for your button you could simply just go
to the website you can right click on
that button and click inspect element
and so when I actually inspect the
element I can see now the button here
you can see it's highlighted in the
upper pane and in the lower pane I can
see where it's linking to it's linking
to network for good comm but here you
can see if I hone in a little and I
could see ID equals header - donate -
button so that's the click ID notice
there's also a class I could have set
the trigger to equal this class or again
I could have set the trigger to equal
the URL or the pain
that this button is pointing to I could
have chosen any one of those but I
decided to go with the ID so this is the
ID I chose and that's the ID I have in
my trigger okay so that is what's going
to fire that event so if somebody clicks
on a button that equals header - donate
- button it's going to fire that event
which is going to equal category header
donate action click and then the label
is going to be page path so now that
we've set up our event we want to test
to see if it actually works so there's
two ways to go about testing an event
and the first way is through Google
Analytics so if we go to Google
Analytics and then we go to real time
okay we can go to events and here you
can see one is already fired so let's go
ahead and go to and test this and go to
the website so if I go here for example
and I click on Almog our alumni okay so
if I click on that you can see I'm under
our family and if I click on that button
then go back to analytics and look at
real time I should be able to see this
event fire so if I click on it I'm gonna
go to network for good now if I go back
to analytics here in real time under
real time under events per second I can
see that event firing category equals
header donate the action equals click
now if I click on the category here I
can see the label the label remember was
page path and here you can see this
event fired on the our family page which
was the page I was just on so that's one
way to test to see if your event works
and in this case analytics recognized
the event so it works it fired and so
therefore it's going to show up under
behavior under events you can go under
overview or top events okay and what am
I going to look for in this case I'm
gonna look for head or donate okay if I
click on head or donate
my category I'm gonna be able to see my
action and if I click on action I'll be
able to see my label in this case
homepage and then later on when the data
propagates and analytics I'll be able to
see under label the page that I clicked
on that hit or donate button which is
slash our family ok the second way in
which you can test to see if an event
fires is if you preview so if I click on
preview and tag manager okay I'm gonna
go into preview mode okay in preview
mode allows you to see in analytics in
tag manager and on the website what tags
are firing so here I can see I'm in
preview mode now so I'm gonna go to the
website and I'm gonna refresh and in my
browser same browser I'm using for tag
manager I can see the tags that are
being fired on this page already ok
because I'm in preview mode so here I
can see remarketing I could see
pageviews I could see Google optimize I
could see some tags that are already
firing on this page now if I click on
this button here by holding down my
shift command and then click on that
button I'll be able to see that the tag
fired in preview mode
there's my event header donate and I
could see it fired so now I can see it
fired in the preview mode so in addition
to Google Analytics in preview mode I
can see that that tag is fired and I
know that it's working so there you have
you have two ways to test to see if the
event fires again you have real-time in
analytics okay so in real-time if you
just go up to real-time all you need to
do is go down to events go to your
website click on the button if you see
it firing in real time then you know it
works the second version or second way
to test your event is through the
preview mode if you see it firing
in preview mode then you know it's also
working okay so let's rehash our steps
first step is we want to be able to
identify what we want to track
okay so it could be this newsletter
signup it can be click on a Facebook it
could be anything we want to be able to
track an image I click on a CTA button
whatever we want to track identify it
second step identify the category action
and label because that's what's going to
show up in Google Analytics
remember label is optional variable or
excuse me value is optional third step
go into tag manager actually set up your
tag and your trigger so if you set up a
tag and it's an event name it GA -
events that way you can see in your list
of tags and tag manager what event
tracking you have already set up so when
you set up your tag you set up your
trigger your trigger is based on logic
that can be a URL it can be a click idea
it can be a class ID whatever you want
to use to fire that event and then once
you do that you want to test it you
could test it in GTM or you could test
it in Google Analytics if it doesn't
fire you want it tweak your trigger if
it does fire then great and then one
thing I would recommend is if you're
setting up various events for your
website that's the best practice what I
would recommend is set up a spreadsheet
and in that spreadsheet you know you
want to put a note
what's firing what are you doing to fire
it could be in this case someone
somebody clicks on the donate Now button
in the header you want to put the tag
name in here the type okay then you want
to record your category action and label
and then the great thing about events is
you could turn those events into goals
and that's as simple as going back in
analytics okay so if I go in analytics
and I go to admin and I go to goals if
you set up a new goal okay all you need
to do is choose custom click continue
you're going to choose event as your
goal name and then from a naming
perspective in Google Analytics for your
goal I would definitely put event first
and then click
how to donate okay so if I click now and
continue what is my category it's equal
to better donate my action is click and
so I can verify to see if this is
working and here I can see in analytics
that the goal would have a point to two
percent conversion rate so that tells me
that the goal is working and I can turn
this event into a goal and when you turn
something into a goal in analytics then
you can measure it across all dimensions
that's what I would recommend if the
event is equal to a KPI or business goal
or it's of importance it's something you
really want to measure okay if it's just
a click say on a Facebook button
I wouldn't recommend setting that up as
a goal okay so once you've set up your
event you recorded it in your
spreadsheet it's firing you want to be
able to then go back into behavior back
into a vance okay you can go to top
events okay so top events tell you by
category as a default what events are
firing or what category is firing the
most okay so if I choose my day range
here I can just go to here today so here
I can see my head or donate button
fortunately for me has the most total
events now noticed in analytics you'll
also see unique events and so the
difference between unique events and
total events is that unique events are
equivalent to one per session where
total events means that somebody can
come to your website initiate a session
and click on that button multiple times
in the same session so if I go to the
AMA Foundation website okay I can click
on that donate Now button three or four
five different times in the same session
so what analytics is going to do is
actually in that session count it once
but accumulate the number of clicks as a
total event for that session so you're
always going to have more total events
than unique events because in some cases
users may click on the button more than
once in the same
and so here I can see total events
unique events and if I added a value to
that event I should be able to see it
here so if I added a dollar as an
example to this particular event because
it had 164 unique events I should be
able to see 164 as my value but since I
see 0 that means that I did not assign
value and so average value basically is
just giving me how much average I have
per event so it's taking into account
the number of or the value the total
value divided by the total number of
unique pages or sessions and so because
I don't have value I'm not gonna have
average value but here you can see
because value is optional here I can at
least see how many events or how many
clicks I receive for a particular button
again it could be a video if I clicked
on this video as an example I can see
how many people actually started it I
could see the unique and the total
events and if I click on label if I have
a label assigned then I'll be able to
see what page triggered that event so if
we go back again to our header donate
button back to category if we click on
label as our primary dimension here we
can see the homepage had the most unique
events then followed by the children's
page the contact form etc so what you
can do in analytics you can also look at
the pages that have driven events so
here I could see the homepage has
accumulated the most total events
followed by the contact us so that's how
you would look at the data in Google
Analytics under behavior under events
and then under top events or overview is
where you can start analyzing your
events tracking so first you need to do
identify it assign a category action
and/or label set up that tag and trigger
once you do that once you test that it's
working this is where you're going to go
to
analyze the data so if you need more
information on Google tag manager I just
briefly showed you how to set up an
event and how to look for an event into
and Google Analytics so if you need more
information you check out this YouTube
video we have on Google tag manager
it'll give you all the direct insights
into what tag manager is all about even
talks a little bit more about event
tracking so thank you for paying
attention if you have any comments about
anything we talked about today regarding
event tracking or Google Analytics or
Google tag manager feel free to leave a
comment under this video if you need
more information please visit simply
learn com thank you again
hi there if you liked this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here